So as the votes continue to be counted in
the 2020 presidential election, it is becoming
more and more clear that Donald Trump really
lost to Joe Biden by a substantial margin
this election.
We're now seeing a difference of three point
eight percent in the popular vote.
That's just over five point nine million votes.
That's a margin that could easily exceed six
million votes by the time all of the vote
is counted.
There are still some states New York state
is one example, 17 percent of the vote in
New York is yet to be counted.
New York State, a state that Joe Biden won
very easily.
So as we get closer to 100 percent in New
York and a few other states, we could be looking
at a six million vote win for Joe Biden.
Now, with Georgia, not everybody has called
Georgia yet.
We're expecting news on Georgia today.
Maybe by the time you listen to this show
or watch today's clips, Georgia will have
been fully certified with Georgia.
Joe Biden would end up with 306 electoral
votes.
That's the same number of electoral votes
that Donald Trump had in 2016.
Now, if you were one of the people who in
2016 said Trump won by a landslide when Trump
had 306 electoral and lost the popular vote
by nearly three million, if that was a landslide,
as Trump has proclaimed, as Kellyanne Conway
has proclaimed in many others, you have to
concede that Biden, winning with three oh
six and a six million vote margin has to be
a doubly large landslide right now to contextualize
this.
If we look at most votes received in history,
no candidate ever received more votes than
Joe Biden did this year other than Donald
Trump.
Also this year before that were Barack Obama's
two elections in 2008 and 2012, followed by
Hillary Clinton in 2016.
Now, in terms of the popular vote margin of
victory, Joe Biden's victory by nearly six
million this year is the 15th largest out
of fifty nine presidential election.
So in the top quarter of popular vote margins,
certainly up there, nowhere near the size
of some of the landslide victories we've seen.
Richard Nixon and Ronald Reagan's wins, for
example, in 1972 and 1984.
Those were by 17 and 16 million votes respectively,
not nearly that big, but it is a very solid
win.
And it comes at a time when the idea of a
mandate and the idea of recognizing that your
opponent won and now gets to govern, that
idea has gone in the trash.
And yet that's not what we are actually hearing
at this point in time.
And of course, when Joe Biden is sworn in
as president, Republicans aren't going to
defer to Joe Biden as if he had a mandate.
I'm expecting some of the biggest, most vile
obstruction from Republicans that we will
see for a long time.
I think it will be worse than under Barack
Obama's presidency even.
And there's a real question as to whether
Joe Biden will even get to govern.
I think that what Joe Biden will get to do,
he will have the privilege of dealing with
Republican obstruction for the next however
many years.
And the real reward that Joe Biden gets is
going to be cleaning up Donald Trump's messes.
And at this point, as Donald Trump has completely
evaporated, he's he's gone with the wind,
so to speak.
Nobody's seen Trump for weeks at this point
other than the Leeth ring ceremony and briefly
taking credit for vaccines.
This is why so much is riding on the two upcoming
Senate runoffs in Georgia.
Biden will be cleaning up big messes from
Donald Trump and his ability to do it will
be greatly impacted by whether Democrats control
the Senate or not.
Now, what's going on in Georgia?
Very tight.
Both races in Georgia are winnable, but they
are very tight.
You've got the incumbent, Kelly Loffler, against
Raphael Warnock race that one right now.
According to the latest polls we've received
this week, it's 49 to 48 in WARNOCK'S favor,
three percent undecided.
What does that mean?
It means it's a tie.
That's that's how we have to operate.
The incumbent Republican, David Perdue versus
Democratic challenger John OSF race.
It's currently 49 49 with two percent undecided.
It's a tie.
These races are winnable, but we have to get
involved in them.
So let's actually go through what we can do.
We're going to be talking about these races
quite a bit.
I will be covering debates if there are any.
It seems David Perdue has already turned down
participating in debates against John USCIRF.
We will be covering live results on January
five.
We're taking these two races very seriously.
If you live in Georgia, you must register
by December 7th, as long as you will be 18
years old by January five, you can register
to vote if you're 17 or.
Right now, but you will turn 18 by January
5th.
You can register to vote.
Right now, we're linking in the description
to the YouTube clip of four where you sign
up and register to vote in Georgia now.
Early voting starts December 14th.
You can request absentee ballots until November
18th.
We are linking to the page on which you can
do that as well.
If you are in Georgia, you can volunteer to
safely knock on doors and get out the vote.
You can volunteer to be a poll watcher or
to monitor the processing of ballots.
And then if you live out of state, you can
still help.
You can phone bank, you can text bank.
If you want to find out more about that, you
can text fair FAAB to seven zero seven zero
zero.
That's the Fair Fight Action Group.
And you can also donate to Raphael Warnock
and or John OSF as well.
So there's plenty that we can all do.
These two races ultimately could decide whether
the next two years look like for a Joe Biden
presidency, we cannot pass.
I don't want to overstate the importance of
these races.
And fortunately, I couldn't possibly do that
because these races are of of ultimate importance
right now.
So we're going to continue talking about that
for the next several weeks and all the way
through January 5th.